propre dans sa tâche
repères
ce village reculé vit de l'élevage de
l'agriculture et de la chasse et de par
son éloignement et l'insécurité dans la
région et est régulièrement la proie de
raids de bandes armées jusqu'à l'arrivée
des faca et des instructeurs russe ils
ont tué trois personnes ici puis ils
sont partis puis ils sont revenus et
nous ont pris une vache ou une chèvre
même de l'argent ils ont tout pris et
puis se sont cachés dans les bois
la présence de ces bandes armées est due
à la richesse minière du sous sol de
cette région nous avons pu nous rendre
sur l'un de ses sites d'extraction
même si le chemin est semé d'embûches en
effet des mines sont parfois posé sur
cette route de terre par chance
celle ci a peut être détectée et
neutralisés à temps mais d'autres
véhicules ont connu un sort moins
enviable comme celui ci quelques jours
avant notre passage
cette partie de la forêt ressemble un
véritable gruyère et pour cause il
s'agit là de mine d'or qui sont en temps
normal
exploité par la population locale mais
voilà elles font également l'objet de
convoitises de la part des rebelles de
bandits armés qui tentent de prendre le
contrôle de ces mines d'or et de leurs
richesses tout en faisant tout en
forçant la population locale à
travailler pour elle s'est tue moi la
zone et si c'est une ville minière et ça
attire les plans dits les étrangers les
jaloux les criminels les brigands ils
viennent ils s'installent dans ce milieu
pour exploitée illégalement la chose du
pays et quand ils veulent comme ça
qu'ils soient des gens qui sont armés
effectivement il menace la population où
les cases et le poil le boot alice et
pour que leur jeu le chant fois libre
afin qu'ils puissent exploiter ce qu'il
veut en temps normal des centaines de
familles jusqu'à 2000 habitants vivent
dans ce village de l'exploitation des
mines d'or qui se trouvent ici a
simplement quelques dizaines de mètres
mais voilà à cause de l'insécurité
à l'heure actuelle les gens ne font que
travailler dans la mine avant de se
replier la nuit dans la forêt et à
plusieurs populations qui viennent
travailler et le soir il en dresse
équivalente est marrante
c'est qu'ils vont dormir en brousse
dorment ils viennent pour travailler me
reste pas sur place parce qu'ils ont
peur que ses passes et pas il en perd
c'est notre problème qui nous dirigent
maintenant même si la présence des faca
et des instructeurs us à améliorer la
situation
il faudra encore du temps pour rassurer
la population et que le sentiment de
sécurité reviennent de façon durable